salve a tutti io c'è il tempo
io sono faccio parte di quel mondo che
appena si sveglia comincia a sognare
apre gli occhi e spera in un mondo
diverso
le mie vite precedenti hanno avuto delle
esperienze molto interessanti importanti
come diceva appunto prima ho creato il
primo modello di banca virtuale in
italia e o
fatto felici forse pochi personaggi i
banchieri che hanno guadagnato molto nel
momento in cui è stata venduta la banca
però ho creato anche degli strumenti di
lavoro molto interessanti e utili per il
sistema finanziario quindi diciamo che i
miei 22 anni di banca e quindi la mia
prima parte di vita è stata interessante
con delle
soddisfazioni personali professionali di
un certo tipo
poi dopo questo tipo di vita e quindi
dopo aver vissuto in un contesto di
bancari collana di perle giacca
doppiopetto grigio tutta precisa ho
pensato basta
all'improvviso una crisi di valori una
crisi economica mi ha spinta a dire
perché perché devo continuare a
guadagnare tanti soldi
ho visto che sono brava posso fare forse
qualcosa di diverso volevo vedere e ho
cercato di capire che cosa volessi fare
da grande quindi dopo 22 anni di banca
ho fatto un percorso a in brasile ho
fatto volontariato per un po e ho capito
che
il sorriso delle persone gli occhi che
ti guardano di questi bambini che sono
felici veramente se tu agisci con un
sorriso con una parola con un messaggio
allora capivo che forse la vita non è
soltanto guadagnare o lavorare la vita
ed aree ed è darsi
e così ho pensato che la mia terza vita
perché poi vi parlerò della prima la mia
terza vita la voglio vivere insieme ai
bambini è quest'uomo e william salice
che ha fondato ha creato una fondazione
che si chiama color your life e a che
fare con i ragazzi quindi scova talenti
in tutta italia e li stimola a crescere
a crescere con dei valori e con dei
principi che fosse sono un po
dimenticati allora bisogna rivalutare i
valori l'etica l'estetica
questo è il mio prossimo progetto quindi
voglio stare voglio invecchiare con i
bambini voglio stare sempre insieme ai
ragazzi per potergli dare per poter
vedere quel sorriso negli occhi che ho
visto in brasile e che continua a vedere
ogni giorno
oggi ho deciso di vederlo però in
situazioni drammatiche situazioni dove
di solito nel carcere si butta la chiave
e rimangono in italia 67.000 persone
rimangono tutte chiuse 20 ore in una
cella tre passi per due e la dimensione
tre persone ci sono in una cella e io ho
pensato chi posso aiutare è facile
aiutare i bambini perché tu comunichi
affetto rispetto attenzione i bambini ci
restituiscono sempre un sorriso
siccome amo le sfide e volevo fare
qualcosa di forte ho pensato dove
nessuno ti restituirà tutto quello che
fai e tutto quello che hai fatto
dove c'è un momento di impatto sociale
forte perché queste donne hanno tutti
dei figli fuori queste donne hanno forse
spesso ai mariti in carcere perché loro
sono complici
volevo vedere se potevo aiutare delle
persone ma al massimo del disagio e
quindi ho pensato alle donne detenute
stiamo facendo un progetto abbastanza
interessante con il ministero
adesso stiamo creando una piattaforma
che serva tutte le carceri italiane per
dare stimolo a tutte queste risorse che
sono abbandonate e che non hanno nessuna
possibilità se non c'è qualcuno che si
impegna abbiamo pensato cosa si può fare
in carcere una camicia un un accessorio
complicato era pazzesco io dopo un anno
sono uscite tutte con l'indulto e ho
dovuto ricominciare
ho detto ho detto che faccio vado via
continua ho deciso di continuare e ho
ripreso invece di fare cose complicate
ho fatto cose semplici quali sono le
cose semplici le borse borse per la
spesa borse per i seminari convegni e ho
chiesto in giro
avete del tessuto da regalarmi perché
devo fare delle prove hanno detto sì
cielo anzi sono felicissima se te lo
regalo e te lo viene a prendere
portatelo perché così mi liberi
magazzini e così ho pensato di poter
fare
scusate un attimo andando avanti pensavo
ci fossero più slide del made in carcere
ho pensato recuperiamo i tessuti di
scarto
mettiamo in piedi una banca del tessuto
raccogliamo da tutta italia i tessuti
l'italiano li facciamo cucine in ba in
carcere
abbiamo forse fatto più di un milione di
borse le vendiamo a toronto a new york a
londra a in germania
adesso il yunus ha fatto le spese
spilline fatte con i nostri prodotti e
parigi quindi è anche italia
lecce un po meno il sindaco magari si
sensibilizzerà su questa operazione
magari ci aiuta ma in tutta italia noi
vendiamo borse per convegni e seminari
semplicemente quindi insegniamo mestiere
e allora l'innovazione dove io mi sento
un'innovatrice sociale un'imprenditrice
sociale dove l'innovazione nel buon
senso nell'applicare il buon senso in
tutto quello che noi facciamo quindi la
creatività come si diceva prima
importantissima e
se è applicata al buon senso diventano
modelli di sviluppo sostenibili sul
territorio che creano benessere diffuso
benessere fra tutti perché poi le
aziende acquistano i nostri prodotti
perché sono belli e si riesce a portare
avanti un progetto un sogno quello di
insegnare a delle donne detenute in un
carcere a cucire nel momento in cui
acquisiscono la dignità del lavoro la
dignità della competenza non tornano più
indietro
ognuno di noi ha voglia di imparare a
fare qualcosa e dimostrare di esserne
capace e così in questo è un libro che
abbiamo scritto 7 mosse per l'italia
perché ho partecipato alla regata genova
a new york con oscar farinetti e
semplicemente ho scritto alcune pagine e
vi volevo far li voleva trasferire in
pillole i miei concetti quello di
innovazione ve l'ho già detto ma
soprattutto più indignazione e meno
omertà più ascolto e meno rumore più
filosofi e meno ingegneri più passione e
meno furbizia più sole mai più nucleare
e più coraggio e meno egoismo
ecco come è nata made in carcere
un'esperienza fantastica che sta
veramente andando avanti sul mercato con
successo e
questa è un'esperienza qual è il flusso
dell'attività raccogliamo e abbiamo un
buon uso del mondo
stiamo lavorando sulla banca del tessuto
insieme alla bocconi
volevo farvi vedere semplicemente 7
pallet di tessuti sono diventati una
borsa ma può essere anche una sciarpa e
quindi l'ingegno alla creatività
applicata al buon senso hanno un impatto
sociale notevole sul territorio e crea
gioia e anche la voglia di mettersi in
discussione
ricominciare daccapo senza mollare io vi
farei vedere il video perché ho visto
che siamo fuori
vediamo un attimo sono 56
no no ma sono infatti grazie sono 50
secondi
vediamole video